here we go from timcast.com gay
conservative Professor under
investigation for offering chocolates to
attendees at an open house I gotta say
hold on hold on there Bertman what kind
of chocolates were they they were
Jeremy's chocolates that's the story a
professor had candy laid out some of
them were Jeremy's chocolates they said
it created a hostile work environment
and put him on leave I gotta say of all
the teachers out there trying to give
candy to children I think this is the
one we need to worry about the least
very good very good yeah Richardson who
was a self-described gay can service at
the college's Human Resources wrote a
letter regarding the matter which was
delivered by a uniformed police officer
unbelievable to his home on Monday
the state center Community College
District informed Richardson who had
been employed at the college for nearly
33 years that he'd been placed on paid
administrative leave putting an
investigation into unspecified
allegations of creating a hostile work
environment along with reportedly
harassing and discriminating against
colleagues based on gender and we are
not fed up with this yet America oh it's
only getting worse
it's getting so much worse but I'm
wondering what happens to actually make
if people will get fed up at what point
they will if they will because I mean I
am of the opinion that we are in a
cultural revolution in the United States
um and I'm not sure how many people here
agree with me that I think everyone does
um and I'm just wondering when the rest
of uh the rest of the
alleged liberals will realize that
progressivism is not liberal that it's
illiberal that it's authoritarian that
it's essentially you know maoism in in
the United States yeah I
it's professor's horrible
I'm not a bad guy
now I want some
I want a little bit yeah
which one is that one we have like two
thousand bars
no I haven't had one you want one no I'm
good
it's not bad
it's really not I got some already not
not a whole bunch of ingredients in it
either it means it's healthy for you I
guess a lot of sugar all right it's
actually not that bad one bar it's like
19 grams of sugar so I guess
if that's all you eat not the worst
thing but
you know we're now in a state where if
you take a dump on a pride flag hate
crime maximum penalty if you try to kill
people on a subway train or threaten to
do so you're the victim of course and if
you're a professor who offers up
chocolate that happens to be made by
Jeremy boring you will be placed on
leave and placed under investigation and
the police will come serve you notice I
mean the left understands the friend
enemy distinction just way better than
the right they understand where they're
at they understand that the key right
now is marking territory knowing who's
on your side they're willing to punish
their enemies and reward their friends
with every opportunity and it's gross
it's difficult in a society we we wish
we wouldn't live that way but we have to
understand that's where we're at right
now and just like you were saying oh you
got to get out of these cities if you're
a conservative or if you're right
leaning or any of this well you also
have to get out of any of these lines of
employment or anything if you are not
along with the progressive agenda
they're gonna come for you no matter
even if you're gay or whatever it
doesn't matter if you disagree with them
on something you will get purged that's
why I like eating the chocolate bars on
the show and making a joke out of it
because I really would prefer it if
people stopped buying Hershey's and
started doing nothing but by Jeremy's
parallel economy Tim actually pays me in
in Jeremy's chocolate that's all he gets
he gets well I get one chocolate bar
every night every night that's it but he
has to eat it I and I have to eat it
even if I'm really full so Tim is
feeding the Irish basically yeah that's
true it's true
Starving Artists what's that that's a
bad joke go ahead
yeah yeah but but this is uh I mean look
this is how the left works though right
so you mentioned earlier someone on the
the subway
threatening people trying to bring them
harm the victim yeah they're a victim
exactly well that's because the left of
course divides people up into victim
classes and oppressor classes and I
think a lot of people on the right don't
realize just how far that goes it's
actually ideological consist
ideologically consistent it doesn't map
out of the world but it's consistent
because in their minds if someone is a
victim any and all behaviors that they
engage in are a manifestation of their
victimhood and if someone's an oppressor
any and all behaviors that they exhibit
are a manifestation of their
oppressiveness so even though you had a
clear situation of self-defense right
the person who is screaming at other
people on the subway he's a victim by
his very nature and can never be
anything else because the left's place
them in this category so his behavior
which we all understand is reasonable
people victimizes others actually makes
him the victim and then the person who
acts in self-defense is an aggressor
because he can't be anything but an
aggressor it's literally his nature it's
the label that belongs on him it's his
category it's literal anarcho tyranny
well it's an inversion of uh aristocracy
right Aristocrats have more privileges
than you they have more rights than you
well because this person is a victim
therefore they are allowed this extra
latitude certain laws don't apply to
them they are above these things because
these allowances have to be made you're
held to a different standard because you
don't have that status
well I feel like oh god well and I'll
also say I mean they actually believe
these people are so so paranoid and
saying they think and this is they
honestly think the True Believers among
them that white people on subconscious
level even if they don't realize it
consciously white people are walking
around thinking how can I kill a black
person they really genuinely think that
that is how white people's minds work in
this culture so when a white person
defends himself from a black person that
black person dies well they were clearly
just looking for the opportunity to kill
a black person and if you want to tell
me they don't actually think that way
then give me any other model of thought
that predicts the outcome of them always
insisting that the white person is an
aggressor in every situation even when
it was clearly self-defense they're
projecting these people feel that way
and their assumption then is everyone
else feels the same way as them
well you remember what Robin D'Angelo
wrote right about everything she said
about black people and also in any given
situation it's not a question of whether
racism occurred it's how did racism
manifest itself
yeah that's insane that's actual
Insanity right but that is what they
believe these are their sacred texts
this is their uh academic literature
it's it's it's not whether or not you
have sinned it is how have you sinned it
you are you are impure from birth
because of the original sin of racism
racism and this is this it's unfortunate
that these things are actually
explain explaining them is fairly
complex oftentimes and the average
person doesn't understand this stuff and
to try and explain it to them just makes
you sound like you're a little on the
crazy side and
I think that the most effective way to
fight this stuff is to inform people of
what's going on so that way they can see
because when you try to engage most of
the leftist arguments at their face the
leftists don't really care which way you
engage the argument because the point is
to get you to engage the argument in the
way that they frame it right on their
terms yeah and that's part of the that's
that is actually the target it's not
whether or not you say the right thing
there is no right thing to say it's that
you're engaging in the argument that
they make like when they make the
argument about the about you know this
person
um this person that that killed the guy
on on the subway they're making you
engage in the argument in a certain way
and and that's the problem if you can
notice that no this is not about uh
Power Dynamic this is about a guy trying
to protect people and if you can make
that if you can make the viewer of the
art engagement see that and see through
their framing that's a way to make
people aware of what's going on but to
just engage with the argument that they
present to you that that ends up making
the average person the fool because they
use things like dual meanings with words
you know the meaning that racism will
change and stuff in this in the middle
of the argument and stuff so it's a lot
of modern Bailey stuff but if you don't
know and you approach the arguments on
their face you'll end up losing well you
you have to reframe it because they
reframe things in such an insane way and
what often happens is conservatives and
this is a point that's been made a
million times it's a dead horse but you
know sometimes a dead horse needs a good
smack or two uh and well I've never well
that's that's because it's a Sheamus
coglin original but they'll say you know
it's so annoying that leftists will
accuse conservatives of being racist and
the conservative goes to all these links
to explain length to explain if they're
not racist and that's true right and
then on the other hand you you'll have
like Fringe conservatives who think that
they're transcending the Paradigm and
going actually I am arrested what you
should be saying is what are you talking
about exactly this has nothing to do
with that you're clearly grasping at
straws like don't even engage with the
issue of race when they bring it up when
they say you've never done sincerely
when you're saying when when you're
saying oh or when you're being told
you're racist the wrong answer is well
let me tell you everyone's racist so
yeah did not show you no that is wrong
that is the that is a failure of of of
of you on your part you have to just you
have to say that you're not racist and
that to even accuse you of racism is
absurd um
right off the bat like you're in my
opinion you should you should reply with
an insult because to call someone an
insult or to call someone racism a
racist is to insult him that's the
intent that they're doing from now on
anytime we ever left us on the show the
first thing I ask is are you racist yeah
good move because then you put him on
the defensive well it's it's because
they have to say yes oh wow we've never
you know because all of us we are not
racist so I don't even know I can't
platform you here that's that's
interesting I wonder if the New York
Times will say about you're an admitted
racist yeah so you're a you're an
admitted you admit you're racist that's
interesting it's horrible yeah we we
shouldn't be platforming admitted racist
on the left isn't Robin D'Angelo an
admitted racist yes and this is the
funny thing 100 I would imagine of
leftists who come on the show would be
self-admitted racists yeah guarantee you
know I mean and then we bring on a
conservative and we're like you've been
accused of being racist like I'm not
racist Tucker Carlson been accused he's
like I'm not racist the left they all
will admit it is this the weirdest time
to be alive it's because they're all
white supremacists this is how they feel
bad about it just remember when somebody
says you're racist or asks if you're
racist or asks if you have like negative
racial attitudes what they're doing is
they're looking at you and they're
asking when did you stop beating your
wife if your response to that is well
I've never I would never do that and
hold on why are you even giving us they
just said they made a ridiculous
accusation with no evidence I figured it
out
how conservatives can win every single
court case every single jury here's what
you do right now I hope the law firm
that's representing Daniel Penny hears
me out
ask every juror are you inherently
racist and if they say yes they say to
the judge I don't think an inherent
racist can be an impartial juror on a
race on on on this racial issue anybody
who's moderate or conservative leaning
or independent will say I'm not and any
leftist will say they are jury heck jury
heck and then you're not kicking off
someone based on their political
affiliation or their Washington Pool
they're admittedly racist and you're
like your honor if the person is
admittedly racist how are we going to
have a fair trial yeah we're not is it
bad that's fair point they had outright
said they're biased against people based
on race then you'll get some middle of
the road guy he's about like no I'm not
a racist I think I'll be fairly okay
that's a really good idea yeah and you
can do it any single jury trial any
single one no matter what it is civil
case criminal imagine this imagine
you're trying to win a defamation case
against the New York Times or something
like that when you're doing jury
selection say are you a racist the
leftists remove themselves so here's a
funny story speaking of jury selection
back in the 1980s my dad got selected
for jury duty he was talking about the
people who clearly did not want to be on
jury or did not want to have to do jury
duty so one guy came in wearing an
American flag tie because he's like look
I have a business to run I don't have
time to be on a jury and then this other
lady when they were asking questions
without them knowing anything about the
case they say Do you believe in the
death penalty she goes yes and I think
he should get it
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time